[Musique]
bonjour nouvelle édition de votre
entretien politique sur tv 78
aujourd'hui avec le maire de vélizy
villacoublay pascal techno bonjour à
vous bonjour vous êtes en poste depuis
2014 c'est votre deuxième mandat à la
tête de cette commune de plus de 22000
avis d'habitants pardon votre slogan
l'an dernier était façonnons vélizy pour
l'avenir est ce que cela reste
d'actualité malgré la crise sanitaire ou
comme certains maires vous avez dû
revoir un petit peu vos plans non ça
reste d'actualité après il est clair que
c'est un peu plus long à organiser
puisque la concertation et les
rencontres avec les villes tient ce sont
plus compliqué que ce que j'avais de
faire dans le mandat précédent
mais on continue à travailler on va
s'organiser différemment pour construire
de nouveaux projets ensemble dans le
planning est qu'en quelques mois de plus
mais l'objectif reste le même vélizy a
déjà beaucoup changé de visage notamment
au cours de votre dernier mandat je
pense à la dalle de de louvois par
exemple il ya encore beaucoup à faire là
si vous voulez plus vous orienter vers
le centre-ville façonner ce centre ville
oualalou voir au fait c'était le projet
c'est dans c'est ce qui avait fait un
peu à peu mon élection c'était de faire
entrer la forêt dans la ville avec des
services et là maintenant ça se termine
dans les jours qui viennent et on a
réussi à faire une vraie vie dans ce
quartier et les gens ont adopté en fait
ces nouveaux jardins ces nouveaux
commerces et c'est vrai qu'on quelque
part une des réussites et maintenant
j'ai un centre ville qui n'en est pas
vraiment un cobaye comme vous dites et
qui est le projet de ce mandat et sur la
confiance que j'ai obtenue à nous voir
en fait maintenant les je suis attendu
et pour transformer le quartier est ce
qu'on souhaite c'est apporter le même
soin qu'on a apporté à louvois au mic
pour en faire un vrai coeur de ville
alors ce ne sera pas la foi qui va
rentrer dans la ville qui a pas la dalle
dg 15 immeubles en l'ombre qui coupent
toute la vie
de ce quartier donc j'espère pouvoir
présenter un projet et construire un
projet en cours en 2021 avec la
population pour transformer ce quartier
et en faire un lieu de vie encore plus
réussie et que l'on voit que
l'environnement toujours comme axe
majeur pour ce quartier mais pour
l'ensemble du mandat
je pense aussi à la chantier de
géothermie qui a avancé aussi qui est un
gros chantier pour la commune donc vous
avez toujours l'environnement dans un
coin de votre tête sur tous les projets
en fait c'est l'environnement a été pris
en compte dans tout ce qu'on fait que ce
soit du service ça soit des grands
projets d'aménagement et il est clair
que lou voiron c'était un des premiers
le premier écoquartier qui a été
labellisé par la région en 2015 et ce
fil conducteur pour tout ce qu on fait
aussi bien dans le transport dans
l'environnement et que la géothermie à
la géothermie c'est ce qui va
transformer tout chauffage urbain de
tous les billysiens pouces 2 en octobre
donc la prochaine saison de chauffe on
aura un chauffage urbain donc toute la
partie collective c'est 90% des
vénitiens qui seront chauffés avec de la
géothermie l'aller le forage de terminer
ce qu'on voit l'image actuellement et
est donc là maintenant on est en train
de se construire le bâtiment qui va
permettre de produire cette ville aux
termites et de transformer les réseaux
sur sur toute la ville pour qu'au mois
d'octobre en fait on aura le chauffage
totalement décarbonés sur toute la zone
d'habitation et 20% du chauffage de la
zone économique
nous évoquons avec vous les différents
dossiers qui concernent cette ville de 2
vélizy comme nous le faisons à chaque
semaine avec les différents maires du
département nous avons parlé
environnement parle on peut être aussi
sécurité s est un problème commun à
plusieurs communes vous votre réponse
c'est quoi c'est plus d'effectifs
vidéo-verbalisation quelle réponse vous
apporter à ces soucis alors les lits et
une ville plutôt calme et je n'ai gagné
d'avancé on
toujours quelques voyous qui essaient de
pénétrer
donc dès 2014 en fait j'avais créé un
hôtel de police avec une police
municipale ont été montés à 21 policiers
municipaux des patrouilles de jour et de
nuit
et donc là on renforce sa avec la vidéo
surveillance qui a été mise avec assez
sûr qu'ils couvrent cinq communes de
l'agglomération est donc là on continue
la vidéo verbalisation est une donnée
supplémentaire mais plus par rapport aux
voyous de la route ou aux voyous aussi
qui ne respectent pas l'environnement
puisque ça permet de voir qu'ils
balancent sont égaux par la fenêtre un
feu ces déchets et donc c'est une brique
supplémentaire mais le quotidien c'est
plus toutes les mesures de prévention
qu'on mène par rapport aux incivilités
on s on a surtout des zones si vite et
on a aussi commentant à des points de
deal qui essaie de se construire donc là
on perçoit directement le trafic pour
faire comprendre que vélizy n'est pas le
bon endroit pour dit les pour des actes
d'incivilité ou tout simplement en fait
pour tout ce qui pourrait perturber la
tranquillité quotidienne des billysiens
revenant aussi sur l'actualité du moment
cette actualité nationale internationale
cette crise sanitaire économique un
centre de vaccination vient d'ouvrir sur
la ville de vélizy est-ce que vous jugez
les moyens dont vous disposez suffisant
aujourd'hui alors les moyens dont on
dispose
ils dépendent que de l'âge il donc selon
hamon a mis tout en oeuvre pour montrer
le centre de vaccination qui a ouvert
hier après il faudra que ça est là c'est
pas forcément la ville oui mais c'est
les doses en fait on est on est pas
maître que des doses
donc là il ya la rl c'est le préfet qui
se battent au quotidien pour essayer
d'obtenir des douze manière générale
pour les yvelines
et pour le central de vélizy classe
toute la difficulté il ya entre un
décalage entre les annonces
gouvernementales
et puis les deux obtenus par chaque
département ont expliqué hier que
quelque part en fait le nombre de doses
on recevait dans le département et 60 de
vélizy et est inversement
proportionnelle aux annonces
gouvernementales
donc j'espère que ça va changer darlas
ont dépassé on avait deux mille doses
qui était prévu on a démarré avec 400
nous annonce un peu moins peut-être la
semaine prochaine mais que le vaccin qui
pourra nous sauver donc j'espère qu'on
mettra tout en oeuvre dans la logistique
pour pouvoir répondre aux attentes de la
r&d nous accompagnent les discussions
aujourd'hui portent aussi sur ce
confinement plus stricte où nous on
verra dans les prochains jours ce qu'il
en est si le président de la république
prend la parole ou non pour annoncer des
certaines mesures nouvelles mesures la
fermeture des écoles aussi peut-être
vous y serez favorable par exemple
non je suis pas favorable mais en fait
aujourd'hui avec les nouvelles mesures
qui sont faites à partir du moment où
maintenant un enfant malade fermer
l'école primaire de la classe oui dès
qu'il ya un sentiment la classe ferme
quelque part le confinement ilan sont
indirectement sans dire mais non je
pense qu'il faut peut-être pour toujours
la mémoire le confinement n'est pas une
bonne idée et à la fermeture des classes
non plus là le ministre que tout pour
les garder ouverte
après il faut juste qu'ils mettre les
moyens aussi en les tests salivaires
il a été annoncé on y voit pas venir et
que la vaccination se généralise et je
pense que si on élargissait le panel de
personnes qui peuvent être vaccinés et
notamment
les enseignants tous les personnels en
contact avec les enfants ça permettrait
de pouvoir éviter ce confinement au film
ans et c'est un échec quelque part et à
partir du moment où on a son masque
on respecte les gestes barrières et où
on vacciner massivement
je pense qu'on peut passer à côté d'un
confinement de confinement c'est ça
serait un échec pour tout le monde pour
le vivre ensemble pour l'économie et
avec des répercussions importantes sur
l'état d'esprit dans quelques mois
doivent se tenir les élections
régionales départementales en tout cas
si l'exécutif décide de les maintenir le
conseil scientifique lui hier s'est
prononcée il a dit que c'était à
l'exécutif de trancher
vous êtes favorable aussi à ces
élections est ce qu'il faut les reporter
ou non une nouvelle fois reporté je
pense que les élections municipales ont
eu lieu il ya d'autres élections qui
cotent organisé et le avec les gestes
barrière qui avait déjà été fait dans
l'urgence en 2000 va on peut être très
bien avoir des élections qui se tiennent
toute sécurité dans au moins au mois de
juin avec des matchs de ce barrière il y
avait la double procuration tubes aussi
permettre pour les plus fragiles de ne
pas se déplacer dans un bureau de vote
comme elle ne se déplace pas dans un
commerce est on
soutien quotidien avec les personnes
fragiles je pense que la foi avancé il
ya des projets qui avancent il ya la
démocratie qui doit aussi permettre
d'avancer de s'exprimer et jeux
politiciens de bas n'a pas lieu d'être
dans la programmation des élections je
pense que non on doit pouvoir les tenir
et aujourd'hui donc c'est avec en plus
le recul on a eu par rapport aux
élections de 2020 qui se sont finalement
bien passé au niveau sanitaire
une dernière question toujours
concernant ces élections valérie
pécresse qui est conseillère municipale
à vos côtés elle fait partie de votre
majorité
elle sera bien évidemment on s'en doute
candidate à sa réélection pour la
présidence de la région ile-de-france
est ce que vous vous allez vous
impliquer dans cette campagne est ce que
vous serez présent sur la liste des
régionales peut-être alors sur la liste
jean sérien aujourd'hui participe d'un
entendu générales régionales aux côtés
de valérie pécresse je pense que c'est
une bonne présidente elle a montré
pendant ce mandat
à quoi servait le conseil général dans
tout le monde sait que il participe
activement à la vie économique ou
transports tout le monde connaît le nom
de la présidente de la région ce qui
n'était pas oublier qu'avant donc là
j'ai tant qu'élu local je participerai
bien entendu à ce que la région se
renforce et que les cruciales sur
présente parce qu'elle n'a pas encore
annoncé et le temps de sa candidature
elle va sûrement venir mais je pense que
quand on a une bonne présidente
on fait tout pour qu'elle continue avec
une équipe qui travaille au quotidien
aux côtés du maire et si elle vous
propose de figurer sur la liste pour
siéger au conseil régional
si je peux être utile je me rendrai
utile mais je pense que je peux être
aussi utile à à côté aujourd'hui les
efficacités des vice-présidents les
petits je travaille aussi bien alexandra
doublage dans l'école où jean-philippe
du moins clément fonds de retraite
efficace aussi la cote ont été entendus
si je peux y participer ça sera avec
plaisir je m'investirai mais ces
problèmes en brut il pourra en encore
plus dynamique l'équipe est là merci
beaucoup pascal thévenot maire de vélizy
villacoublay d'avoir été avec nous pour
ce numéro de l'entretien politique l
émission revient la semaine prochaine
avec un nouvel élu du département des
yvelines
[Musique]